the 2020 all-star game
i'll tell you what this is fun this is
getting good people
as a fan we love competition and they
are competing right now
this is amazing to me to see the
intensity
everyone is out of their seats i haven't
seen this much excitement
in an all-star game maybe ever it's the
69th
annual nba all-star game you know you
sometimes take it for granted you know
what i mean but it's nothing like the
camaraderie being here with all the guys
it is always an honor and a privilege to
be honest wearing
number 24 tribute to kobe bryant lebron
wearing
number two on the back of the uniform in
tribute to uh
kobe's daughter gianna part of the new
format each quarter is worth a hundred
thousand dollars that goes
to the charity of the winning team's
choice
here's lebron whipping cross court kawhi
leonard yes
from downtown
anthony davis kevin walker getting hot
here early
it's a three-point fest going on out
i can jump here
[Applause]
three of his first quarter really
feeling it
[Music]
and off the steel it's hard
with the setup
and with team lebron winning the first
quarter 100
000 goes to chicago scholars charity
on to the second quarter there's got to
be some type of sense of
urgency for team giannis to get a win in
one of these quarters to reward his
charity as well
right there oh booker
a little bounce
take those ankles
erupted here in the second quarter now
look how hard
he's in nba finals mode right now
again he's seven of eight from downtown
no more threes
no more threes bro y'all got the 90 yep
boston one
[Applause]
did he go through the legs here the
nutmeg he sure did
he's done that a lot this season so the
honest squad leads 36-25
[Music]
but team giannis has defeated team
lebron in the second quarter 100
000 dollars go to the after-school
matters charity third quarter just
underway oh there's embiid passing out
of three
[Applause]
to start this third quarter talking
about the guys hopefully hamping it up
for free yes and there's a three-pointer
by
giannis and it does right back
from downtown
with a little windmill wind up oh
pass and go bear puts it down
nice password here and simmons with the
finish
pretty young oh one of the boss he's
young
talking
this is important two minutes here to
try to win this quarter and that hundred
thousand
for your charities and the game is tied
up this is good everyone's up broke
for
[Applause]
[Applause]
as this is quarter gets underway the
taunted scorer
157 no clock involved
and reggie i like this target score it's
like a pickup game
yes first team to 157
the game
with the finish and chris paul
continues here struggling here to start
this four
five blue players in the paint though
these teams are playing hard right now
there's paul he's been hot from three
and he does it again
and look who's getting ready to check in
the cavalry for
team lebron lebron
and they are what 13 away from the win
yes but davis right back
[Applause]
[Music]
look at lebron james playing defense
right there
played by lapland and
ball something you rarely see you gotta
admit the intensity
and the level of play has picked up here
in the fourth
haunted from the corner hits a free
race to 11 now so the tide of one forty
race
race to 11.
by anthony davis to see these guys play
with this kind of intensity
to go out and compete on both ends of
the floor this is this is beautiful to
watch
up 150 to 148 letters
but the pull up team lebron with a
chance to go ahead here
[Applause]
you can't tell me these guys aren't into
it look at the bench look at both
benches
they've been up this whole fourth
quarter all right here's lebron
rejected let's see the call on the floor
was good baskin
is there enough evidence to overturn
that
this is so close don't jump on no basket
and lebron cannot believe it
lebron against needing a free for
[Applause]
[Music]
hits on both and essentially
next basket wins lebron played
bariatrics
captains guarding one another here's the
pass to davis
we got a whistle the foul is called
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
an all-star game that has to be
considered very successful because of
what took place
in the fourth quarter i loved the
intensity i saw
in this fourth quarter this fourth
quarter is
probably one of the best fourth quarters
in 25 years